the direct path
number three
if you haven't yet highly recommend
watching the first
two videos we made on the direct path
this is the direct path to
self-realization
of god of source
of the one infinite creator that we are
beautifully expressing itself
this is a special episode because
points number one through four
will be the classic direct
path and then points five
through eight will be key
insights that happen on the journey
of self realization
i look forward to sharing those with you
number one seek
your ass off
the most true thing
is your impulse to seek
your impulse to know yourself
is the most true thing
it may
guide you away from making money
seeking truth
as a principle
will transcend your desire to make money
how dedicated are you to
truth or are you okay
with being ignorant
are you okay with the veil
are you okay with being lost in the
labyrinth
of your own creation
or do you want to know yourself
as god as source as the one
infinite creator expressing itself do
you want to
anchor non-duality in
your essence
how bad do you want that truth it's up
to you
there's the classical
ants way that is typically referred to
by the planet
oh this person went off into the
mountains
and spent three decades
at a monastery and then became
enlightened
that's the ants way
that it takes three decades 30 years
and then you have the bird's way
the bird's way
also referred to as satori
with more sudden enlightenment
and that is the entire purpose of this
video series on the direct path
the whole purpose of the direct path
is the bird's way it's to catalyze
satori as quickly as
possible
there have been many examples
at events with really strong
non-duality teachers
where participants in the events have a
profound revelatory satori moment
and they get it
and that's enlightenment but then they
have to re-baseline
they have to do the repetitions to make
infinity home
to really truly anchor non-duality
god source infinity in their essence
and it requires to do those reps
unsubscribe
from the matrix
subscriptions
which you were baptized into
by modern society
unsubscribe from those matrix
subscriptions
and vigorously subscribe
to awakening
subscribe to union
that is what is meant by the sanskrit
word
yoga is union
or greek hypnosis
is union with god with
source with piercing the veil
and understanding yourself as
the one infinite creator expressing
itself
seek your ass off that
is the truest thing
about us is that seeking impulse
to stop
your suffering
i was fortunate enough
to attend four
10-day silent vipassana
theravada buddhism meditation retreats
what you do there is you
gain control of the monkey mind
the monkey mind is what is excessively
causing suffering
when you have no control over the
focus of your awareness it is going to
run you around in depression
pain anxiety anger
you're going to react rather than
be patient and create a pause and
observe
and then wisely engage
this is critical because
if you want to do well shooting
three-pointers you have to go and
practice
if you want to be really strong at
playing the violin
you have to go practice
but for some reason
people don't think that's it's important
to practice taking control of their
monkey mind
at these longer 10-day meditation
retreats
when you can't talk when you can't look
at other people when you can't use
technology and
all you're doing for 10 straight days is
doing the direct
most conservative teachings of the
buddha
you surgically
methodically over those 10 days
hone in on the eradication
of the most root level monkey mind
and you anchor more of the god
of the source of the infinity within you
it's a huge level up
learn how to create that pause learn how
to unsubscribe from the matrix
subscriptions
that are disabling you from
going for 10 days the vipassana
retreats are completely free of cost
they're donation based you make a
donation after you complete
it
and they provide you with housing and
food
i'll put the link in the bio below for
those that are interested
what we do when we move ourself away
from suffering
away from victim consciousness
towards that positive
expressions of existence we move more
and more into creator consciousness
we just did a video on creator
consciousness as well
which i'll put the link in the bio below
for you
that transition from victim to creator
consciousness
and the ability to methodically
manifest
a divine north star
a transcendent noble aim
that brings value to civilization
that is in service to others that solves
things like the sdgs
that is creator consciousness
taking control of its reality
based on its thoughts
that's what the one infinite creator
does at its optimum
is that it moves away from that victim
consciousness towards the creator
consciousness
all right
number three peel
layers of identity
so
once we
have
a great amount of sensitivity
with the seeking
impulse and the pause
that we've created to distance ourselves
from suffering towards flourishing
we can begin to do things like identify
ourselves as an
onion and that
all of the layers of the onion are all
of the layers
of our identity
this means for me it would be something
like
my name is atlas and i'm 28 years old
and i'm armenian and i live in los
angeles and i'm an entrepreneur
that's already five layers of identity
and most people are carrying around
5 10 15 20 layers of identity
but how many people are carrying around
them their most
pure bear knowledge
of who they truly are as the non-dual
awareness that is
god or infinity expressing itself
and so then we methodically undergo the
process of
slowly peeling these layers of identity
on the onion until we recognize the pure
bear awareness
and this can be thought of as awareness
without coloration
awareness with coloration or
consciousness with coloration
is when consciousness is immersed in
thoughts emotions
feelings or objects
but consciousness or awareness without
coloration
is that pure bear emptiness kind of like
we have two examples here
the first one is the classic screen
so this is the screen
which now approximately four billion
people around
the planet
have and so this is a very modern day
way of understanding it your awareness
without coloration
is the screen
without any images or movie happening
on it as soon as you unlock
this device and
begin browsing applications that is
coloration
that is images that is movies
that's when you're scrolling the social
media you're watching videos
that is coloration so
the example here with the screen
is a great practice because it's all
around you your monitors your
televisions these screens
the tablets the laptops
practice looking at them when
there's nothing on the screen when
they're powered off
and then recognize your own bare pure
awareness
that is like that before coloration
we have another very strong
example here as well which is
the paper
this right here is the paper
with words which is with coloration
which is the way that we normally
experience
life is we experience our consciousness
our awareness is constantly immersed in
objects thoughts feelings emotions
these words
and so practice this also
is what happens when you
look at the paper itself that the words
are written
on
that paper in itself
that these words are written
on is
the primal pure bear awareness
that is god
that is source that is infinity
expressing itself
and then this the words
are the thoughts the emotions the
feelings
the objects that that pure bear
awareness
experiences
create this juxtaposition with
the resources of the paper
and the screen
in order for you to
more and more recognize what
god is what source
is what non-duality is what the one
infinite creator is that juxtaposition
helps
most of consciousness
is colored
and lost in the labyrinth of its
creation and coloration
but when consciousness undergoes the
process of reflecting on its own
existence and creates
this juxtaposition it makes this pause
it's able to reflect on that pure bear
awareness
like a paper without words or like a
screen without images or movies
and then it recognizes i get that now i
get it
and then we sort of re-baseline
ourselves again like doing repetitions
to more and more of
this self-realized pure bear awareness
and that inches us
into number four
which is realizing non-duality
once we do those repetitions
in that juxtaposition
and we're really starting to
relax more and more into the pure
bear awareness
and you can practice these repetitions
you can practice them with me right now
here's the difference right now
we're training our attention
focusing our attention
it's entrained on the images
and the words and the
feelings and emotions
and object of the device
and if we just relax
our awareness relax
the awareness on
pure bear awareness
unjust the i am
on just the essence of being
relax the awareness relax it
back back it should feel like you're
relaxing your awareness
and you're sitting more and more
back in your own
consciousness pre-coloration
just that very beingness that very
is-ness that very
i am-ness pre-coloration
that is god that is source
that is infinity
that is what we are and we are
expressing ourselves
and now you can engage your awareness
again
into coloration and you can sort of see
that
juxtaposition that we created right
there
we can do that literally anytime
throughout the day and if we learn
how to do that these repetitions
throughout the day
what's going to happen is you're going
to more
and more recognize
god you're more and more going to
recognize
source the one infinite creator
what's going to happen is that you'll
recognize
that you are it because awareness itself
consciousness being aware
is it so you are it i
am it we are it
our very beingness our very i am-ness
our very presence is it
and then
the feelings of non-duality set in
once we begin
uncovering ways of
understanding like what
what al-wujud teaches
i made an entire video on
my enlightenment thanks to that
brilliant sufi metaphysical
expression and i'll put the link in the
bio below to that video as well
but in essence non-duality
especially really sinks in
when we understand that what that aloo
jude
is not just the unity of all being in
existence
but it's actually the unity of all
finding
and then what you do is you begin
to visualize all
8 billion humans at
all of their different stages
from egoic consciousness
all the way to enlightenment
undergoing a process of finding
finding yoga union
hypnosis
the mystical
merging and recognition
piercing the veil self-realizing oneself
as god as source as the one infinite
creator
and when you visualize and hold all
eight billion humans
as a shared god as a shared
source as a shared infinitude
of their consciousness their awareness
that is all
simultaneously in different
levels of finding
undergoing that process of piercing the
veil
that is profoundly awakening and that is
just
this creation that is just one creation
that is just one
planet earth that has eight billion
humans that are undergoing
their own unique union
with god
non-duality is the recognition that all
8 billion
people share their consciousness
that they share their awareness that we
all come from the same source
we come from the same god we are that
we are god we are source and that we
share
our process of this entire
expression of creation and
all eight billion undergoing their own
unique
finding their own unique union
with god and that is beautiful because
we made this we are the one infinite
creator expressing itself
and we can make incredible things
like this reality where
we dream this up and immerse ourselves
into it as these first person
perspective characters
that
undergo a process of forgetting
how cool is it that god can veil itself
that we can veil ourselves
what a unique thing that is
it's magic
it's unbelievable
we veil ourselves
and then undergo a process of finding
it's so majestic
it's mystical it's beautiful
and that's why this is the coolest game
in town
infinity expressing itself is the
coolest game in town
that's what we are that's what we've
been doing that's
what we're going to keep doing and
that's why
the realization of nonduality of god
source infinity what that does is it
makes you experientially embodied
the recognition of our awareness being
eternal
being infinite and being bliss
and being peace sachit ananda existence
consciousness bliss
and so that's why enlightenment
is imperturbable peace
and causeless joy because
you know you become a gnostic being
of non-duality of god of source
and you understand what this is
and that's what i wish upon every single
one of the people that are taking in
this direct
path content is for you to undergo
your own finding
with greater signal
and that's what these direct path videos
are
they're a compression
five years ago i was playing clash of
clans on three accounts simultaneously
and today five years later i'm
enlightened
i spent so much time dedicating myself
to
truth over everything in order to find
this as a
massive synthesis of all of the global
perennial mystic spiritual traditions
going and parsing all of those for
signal studying the sciences
in massive depth studying consciousness
in massive depth studying
art and the way to disseminate this in
incredible
efficacy all to be able to package
together
this now in these direct path teachings
and other content that we are
disseminating
to aid you in your finding
to aid that seeking impulse that is the
truest thing about you
to accelerate that the direct path
is the bird's way the direct path is
meant to
catalyze satori faster you don't
need 30 years of being
in a mountain monastery you need to
dedicate yourself
to truth over everything else
relentlessly and
it will yield that's what happened for
me
i put it above money i put it above
everything
relationships everything i put it above
everything
and i just went relentless at it and it
yielded
in five years
the way that i feel right now is
imperturbable peace
it's causeless joy it's absolute
bliss equanimity it's
infinity it's a truly embodied
self-knowledge of myself as god
as source as the one infinite creator
and that feeling is worth
all five years of seeking
and now the way that i get to share and
help others
is worth it
it's worth it being untriggerable
being so deeply rooted
in truth in imperturbable peace and
causeless joy
that all you do is butterfly effect
the absolute highest morality of
non-duality
of god of unity consciousness
everywhere
that is ultimately
the highest expression of infinity is
when
infinity recognizes itself and what it's
doing and what it is
you deserve that
dedicate yourself to truth above
everything
that seeking impulse above everything
dump everything else unsubscribe from
everything else
and focus on just truth focus on just
seeking
focus on the direct path teachings
focus on all of the different modalities
on the big buffet
that exist the paths
are many but that end
is one
all right so that's
numbers one through four
which are the direct path
teachings for this
episode and now what i'm going to share
with you
are additional key insights
these are points five through eight
which are key
insights on the direct path
journey very important i'm looking
forward
to you taking them in
okay
point number five drill
to water
what we mean by water is we mean
full enlightenment we mean non-duality
we mean god self-knowledge of
god of source of your infinitude
that's what we mean by drill all the way
to water
go all the way
because many people
including myself on this journey
sample a lot of these different paths
that we were talking about
that all end in that one
and what happens is it's good to sample
these different paths
and to become a strong synthesis of
these different paths
because it wasn't just the theravada
buddhism
10-day meditation retreats of the
pashana
that i sat but i sat with zolchen
as well and i read
the dao de jing
and i studied the
other mystic traditions across
the spiritual branches
which is why i uncovered beautiful
things like wadat al-wujud of the sufi
metaphysics the unity of all finding
and i underwent plenty of entheogens
as well unleashing god within
5meodmt lsd
mdma psilocybin
incredible experiences
that are all synthesized into
my awakening and enlightenment
but it's very very critical
that there are also these direct path
teachings
and we've put the links in the bio in
the first
two episodes as well
to these two teachers and we're gonna do
it again
for this episode the two
who i believe are the best direct path
teachers today
that i am aware of that are most
relatable
in my opinion are the first one
is
in his mirror talks
podcast specifically
go and watch that and then
second is rupert spyra
in his
teachings of the direct path as well
and his channel
and that link is also in the bio below
and those direct path teachings
can help along your
finding process make it so that you
don't
necessarily have to go to the 10-day
silent
meditation sits
to me those are still extremely
important because they create
the pause and they create the immersion
into the oceanic-ness
but that's the beauty of all 8 billion
that undergo their unique combinations
of finding
and so yours is going to be unique but
the direct
path
accelerates that finding
for self-realization for an embodiment
of the self-knowledge
of god of source of the one infinite
creator
and i
i can tell you that it's very
tempting to stop
and to think that you have it and this
sort of leads into point number six
as well because the intellectualization
of god or source of non-duality of
infinity
is very much kind of what happens when
you're maybe
getting towards that 90 percent of the
way there
as you're drilling down to water
that you get a little bit of you get a
little cupful
you don't hit the massive ocean
which is that satori moment
and which is that ego's gone
boop all self-identity
is gone you are just the non-dual ocean
but when you get that little cup full
and it's so tempting to go this is it
this is it i got it i got it i got it i
got it
i got it because it was
so much my experience as
well which was that there was this
really deep
sort of intellectualization of
like here in point six that
i'm speaking about enlightenment about
non-duality about infinity about
consciousness
about god's source as
really the unity of all being in
existence and i'm speaking about it from
that perspective
i'm speaking about it from a very
oceanic perspective
which is great and it was a little bit
experiential for me because i had
undergone these sorts of experiences
but really really just
recently just very very recently here at
the end of
2020 did i
finally have a satori moment
so again it's going to be tempting
because you can say
oh okay i'm good i can go back to
chopping wood and carrying water as they
say
before enlightenment chop would carry
water after enlightenment shop would
carry water
and so you might just get that one
little cup and then say
aha back i go to the
economic machine and back i go into
doing what i was doing before you know
chop would carry water but
it's crazy because you go back
without going all the way without
drilling
all the way to water and drilling all
the way to water
is so damn important
in the seeking process and there will
likely be a moment as you go back out
with the one cup of enlightenment that
you have
that will indicate to you that oh [ __ ]
the seeking impulse is still here and
that's usually how you can tell
is if the seeking impulse hasn't
dissipated
it means that you haven't found it yet
you haven't found
the diamond necklace that is already
around your neck
only when you figure out
the diamond necklace is already around
your neck
only when you truly experience
feel that and you recognize
that you are god that you are source
that you are the one infinite creator
expressing itself and the diamond is
around your neck
and the diamond is around everybody's
necks in their own unique process of
piercing the veil and finding themselves
as
god only when you realize that
fully embodied and you have this
imperturbable peace and causeless joy
and the feelings of true eternal
infinite aware
bliss peace
that's when you've had a satori moment
that's when you've had enlightenment
and i again am only doing these direct
path teachings now
because i have had that
i was not ready to do this before
even just a week ago or so
and that's the beauty of this
process is that
what i'm doing right now with sharing
the direct path
it came exactly when it was supposed to
come which was
after my satori moment
the transmission here would be extremely
distorted
which also leads me into some of the
next points
but you can tell when somebody has not
drilled all the way to water
and when they are from a very
intellectual space talking about it
versus from a very deeply experiential
space and you can actually feel that
energetically
as well and practice the process of
deciphering
between that
okay so this leads me into
these
points which here
number seven is the middle path
which is a very famous phrase of buddha
and so many of the other perennial
spiritual mystic traditions which talk
about this middle path or this middle
way
and
what happens is if you especially if you
don't get
all the way to water this is why i call
this also the goldilocks zone which is a
great analogy for
also our not only the temperature of
that soup or porridge that you're eating
but also the perfect
orbital of
planet earth and how it enables
the blossoming
of sentience
to then pierce the veil and recognize
itself as the one infinite creator
because what happens is if
you go to
the process of drilling the well to
water
and as you're drilling the water what
happens is
you stop
usually what you see is what i wrote
here as
too low which means something like
maybe you're obsessively
in the space of
shadow work
that seems to be a very
common place for people
to get stuck is they get stuck
in doing some sort of shadow work about
their
traumas and about their history and
lineage
the point is to integrate that
and move forward and continue the
seeking impulse
don't sit there and play back on rewind
over and over and over again
and that's what can happen in this too
low
area now on the other
side of it is the too
high and what i mean by
too high is
what can happen to people when they
have satori
and they begin undergoing
a process of
being from a place of non-duality or
self-knowledge of god or source of the
or the one infinite creator
what can happen is that they basically
do not
do the next point
which is the tantric path
if you go so high
that you don't actually weave
your non-dual
god source self-realizations
into the
life around you
then in a sense you are missing the
point
you get to express yourself however you
want as
infinity if you want to go too
high go for it if that if that's your
expression go for it
if you want to go too low and
stay in the process of shadow work or
whatever
it's your unique expression
but that middle way that middle path
when you drill
all the way to water and you have satori
you have the enlightenment you are it
embodied
then the tantric path which is the
weaving
of the self-realization into the life
around you
and then you undergo the process of
catalyzing
other people's findings other people
piercing the veil
and realizing themselves as the one
infinite creator that they are
that's it that's
it
drill all the way to water
and then undergo the tantric path
of weaving
it's the goldilocks zone that's the
middle path not too high
not too low
and then the number eight
the bucket of crabs
this one oh my goodness
oh man given the fact that i was just
sharing with you a moment ago that this
really true satori
was about a week or so ago for me
that immediately what happened was this
massive flare-up this like huge egoic
flare-up of family friends
that are saying something along the
lines of
this is what the bucket of crabs means
is if i can't
have it neither can you and then the
bucket of crabs as they're trying to
pull down the crab that's
in escaping the bucket becoming
enlightened
having a satori moment beginning to
express from a place of non-duality from
a place of infinity from a place of god
or source
and you can tell that it's egoic
consciousness you can tell that it's
egoic
family friends and especially people
online
i began messaging some of the direct
path
teachings that i had been doing into
some of the
communities online and there were some
people that were very
kind and there were other people
that were obviously not realized
because realized people they
don't leave comments
that are bully
right realized people realize that you
are god and i am god we are the same one
infinite creator expressing itself and i
would never
bully you because i just be hurting
myself
and that's the profound realization
and so now you can understand also what
happens when
people in the highest positions of power
the fortune 500 ceos the un general
assembly
the usa congress the 2200 billionaires
the 225 000 ultra high net worth people
around the world
when they on that spectrum from the go
at consciousness to non-dual
consciousness
when they pierce the veil
and awaken to the true god source
infinity that they
are that we are all expressions of
that is likely the most
upstream malady that civilization faces
so to catalyze the satori of the people
in
the greatest positions of power around
the planet is
critical most upstream
and people that have undergone
satori will be very
healthfully engaging with you
throughout your seeking
so a great indicator of somebody that is
truly
enlightened is someone that engages
with you on your journey of seeking
and finding as
a true pure mirror
of god of the one infinite creator
so that you'll be able to tell from your
engagement
with this enlightened being that
their soul
role within that engagement
is to be a pure
mirror of the absolute highest god or
source
to you so that you
can understand in your seeking and
finding
process your own self-realization your
own piercing of the veil
to understand your own godness
sourceness one infinite creator
number eight is also really important
because
what you have to do at that point when
there is this sort of egoic bucket of
crabs
consciousness is that you have to
gracefully and that's why
i've been i've been underlining
gracefully throughout the
the last couple
streams is because
the key word is gracefully to gracefully
engage with your egoic family friends
in a way that gives love and wisdom but
that is also
removing yourself it's something that
people struggle with a lot is the
process of
creating distance between
very egoic levels of consciousness
between
themselves between their family or
friends
and themselves undergoing
their enlightenment and they
think that they have to attend to this
no
you don't actually you attending
to egoic levels of consciousness while
you're holding your gold nuggets of
enlightenment
all that happens is the egoic
consciousness hits your gold nuggets
out of your hand that's all that happens
wisdom is in a sense a step above
love because love can be
so blind wisdom is knowing how to step
back and remove yourself
because what happens is when you remove
yourself
we talked about this in the last stream
on creator consciousness
is it enables the space to open up
for new co-creators
that have themselves
anchored non-dual awareness and have
themselves become
manifestation machines around
the architecting of a more prosperous
abundant future for all
creating that space to actually have
those co-creators land in your life
so remove yourself from the egoic
consciousness create the space to have
the new co-creators come in and you'll
be surprised at what will happen when
non-dual awareness begins hanging out
together
wow that is some beautiful stuff
pure mirrors of the one infinite creator
engaging with one another and
architecting
a more abundant prosperous future that
is an enlightened civilization
and we can get there for everybody and
so to be
creator consciousness towards that as
our civilizational north star
is critical it's fascinating how
meanwhile
strangers will profoundly thank you it's
fascinating because
not only is the co-creators that come
into your life but there's
so many people on this channel and i
love you so much
that comment on these videos and that
say things like
what a wonderful lecture or that
this is exactly what i needed you've
influenced my satori moments
that i love you very much atlas things
like that
and these are people
many of which i have never met before in
person
so quote strangers but really they are
though of the one the ones expressions
and so i'm very grateful for you
stepping forward and saying those things
and that we should do our best to step
forward and say those things
to one another
and this is why we make
the content that we made around the
pixar film
soul which just released yesterday
and we made a piece of content on that
thanking their incredible animation and
story team
for inching us closer
and closer towards an enlightened
civilization by providing us
with great educational and entertaining
content like that especially for
children
for them to undergo a self
inquiry into what is
soul
and it was beautiful because they even
had the incredible
white source as well in it
so i hope this has been a
solid direct
path video for you again
points one through
four are very much the
direct path and so
seeking your ass off
stopping your suffering dedicating
yourself
vigorously to awakening and truth and
union
and that bird's way
and then moving yourself into a state of
creator consciousness
peeling your layers of identity down to
that bureau of pure bear awareness
leveraging the
tools that we have like paper without
words in the screen without
movie or images and practice those
super fundamental
realizing non-duality how you are it how
our awareness is shared and how its
nature is eternal infinite aware bliss
peace and then these other key insights
number five through number eight
are key insights along the journey of
self-realization things like drilling
all the way to
water things like having an experiential
anchoring of god source and infinity
versus just intellectualizing it
being very aware of that middle path
that goldilocks
zone the tantric aspect to it
weaving the realizations into the nod of
life and then also being very aware of
the bucket of crabs and the egoic
consciousness trying to pull it down
wisely removing yourself opening
yourself up to new creators
and then
inching ourselves closer and closer
hopefully with the bird's way
towards satori towards awakening
towards union towards enlightenment
again union with what what is this
direct path about
the direct path is about the union
of you with god with source
with the one infinite creator a true
self realization
a true piercing of the veil
so that you recognize that diamond
necklace that is already
around your neck
create that juxtaposition of awareness
with coloration versus awareness
without coloration and you'll recognize
that diamond around your neck
and you'll do the repetitions to make
that home and to make that god
source
one infinite creator home
i love you very much thank you
for this third direct path video
together
i'm very excited
and grateful to be able to be
passing along the
self-realization and hopefully
positively
impacting the finding that you are
undergoing
let me know where you are at in your
journey
in the comments below where you're at
which ones of these points helped you
out how they helped you out
our email simulation series gmail.com is
in the bio you can always send us a
direct
email about your experience and where
you're at
and over time we'll be doing more and
more community work
around helping people with their
journeys
in that seeking impulse
that finding that union
that's a main cornerstone of our channel
is helping
with that so we'll be making more videos
on the direct path as well
in the future so
like the video if you haven't subscribe
if you haven't
and share the video with people that you
know that this would be
impactful for so share it
and we have lots of goals here in los
angeles
around especially helping many of the
influencers and celebrities with the
most
impacting clout undergo similar
processes
of self-realization
and also disseminating animated series
to the planet to help them with the
process of self-realization for kids and
adults so if many goals and aspirations
and
your support helps us tremendously
and you can find all of our links in the
bio below to help support us
as well in that endeavor
all right congratulations on the
progress
that you've made in the
self-realization in your
union with god union with source union
with the one infinite creator
and then expressing yourself from that
union
that's the self-realization followed by
the self-actualization
which is being the highest possible
expression in that tantric path
from the highest morality and
architecting
that more abundant more prosperous more
flourishing more well-being
for all
thank you i love you
let's help with the diamond necklace
that is already around everyone's
neck
that seeking impulse
it's most true
dedicate yourself to truth and it
will yield
do
you